[Music]
what are you doing here seriously you're
just like a poor such a [ __ ] get your
thing get the out of here
grupe
getcher and security will escort you the
paddy here Kim Kardashian catches Scott
Disick hiding a girl the intense moment
kicked off at the end of Sunday night's
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
Scott relapse
yes oh he drank stuff was writing me
Simon was writing me oh this is so sad I
can't believe it so mad at him after
Scott found out his ex Courtney went out
with another man Scott went partying
while on a trip to Dubai this is like
probably the worst thing I could ever
cure ever the next morning Scott quietly
tells a show producer there is in fact a
girl at his place
a hard time
yeah a member of Kim's entourage found a
person Scott's living room and once they
realize Scott's bathroom door was locked
Kim cracked the case because the
bathrooms locked I'm not stupid should
we go in there
unfortunately the encounter was a
cliffhanger for next week's episode so
we'll have to wait until then
[Music]